imagine a world where everything is
decided by games war politics it's a
world where you need to be good at games
or you have no life wow that sounds
perfect for me as a shut-in gamer who's
also a genius socially adjusted
charismatic guy that all the ladies are
gonna fall for this that's totally
accurate and that's my gamer sister lady
pipeline who's not related by blood did
I mention she's still not related by
blood cuz it would be totally weird if
she were related by blood so it's a good
thing she's not related by blood at all
I am 11 though lalalala I'm not
listening
what's this message what is this another
transporter to a fantasy no brilliant
and remember don't cheat because no one
here cheats except for that one time
were literally everyone here cheats hey
you for that bag of coins I'll bet you
that amount multiplied by the number of
women I've slept with deals haha joke's
on you a bag of coins times zero is
still zero alright are you familiar with
the rules of poker yeah yeah no items
final destination Fox only Royal Flush
baby that's over one in six million
chance how how in my world we have this
thing called believing in the heart of
the cards ignore that just who are you
people
I'm glad you asked yes we are the
legendary
I'm sorry did you say something you know
you must have heard of
uh you keep moving your mouth but not
saying anything that's cuz that's our
name it's nothing we just leave our name
blank can I just call you blank then I
don't know I feel rolls off the tongue
better tasteless fanservice character
come on in hey I'm important and useful
have you know I'm the daughter of the
former King yeah okay mr. flirt me all
right I'll prove it to you I challenge
you to rock-paper-scissors okay to make
it easy for you I'm gonna go wrong okay
step that just means don't go scissors
[Laughter]
but wait that means you guys are
actually really good you made me do this
by applying that much mental pressure on
me
yeah no you're just a [ __ ] idiot yeah
[ __ ] idiot Jesus Christ Stephanie yes
Stephanie I've never met someone so
stupid oh my god just tell me what you
want tell me everything you know about
this world there are 16 total races in
this world and our race is called a
manatee you mean humanity Noah manatee
humanity humanity humanity humanity
humanity manatee why do you keep saying
it like that what what's wrong with what
I'm saying okay what do you call one of
our kind a human so what's the name of
that as a whole humanity no its humanity
humanity humanity humanity humanity
humanity you reduce this character and
nobody loves you I challenge you to a
game for what to become king of humanity
humanity
I will eat your babies are we doing this
or not all right I'll agree as long as
your next line will be this must be the
work of an enemy stand I'm sorry was
that meant to be a reference of some
kind are you serious wait I got it thank
you
[ __ ] persona reference god
[ __ ] dammit we'll play chess for the
crown this is fantasy chess but it's
basically like normal chest basically
like normal chess got it alright I move
pawn to d5 see the rules are just like
you activated my trap card I sunk your
battleship I roll in that 20 and cast
magic missile while adopting your goblin
tribe isn't supposed to be chess
damn it I'm in a tight spot now move
your last pathetic piece Sora my board
has no pathetic pieces but it does have
the unstoppable Exodia
okay now we're just reapplying yugioh
and that's checkmate I lost I had no
idea there was someone in this world
that's good at chess that was easy
who's next I'm next and what do you
offer how about this library containing
all the knowledge held in his world lame
how about more fanservice do another
shameless girl to add to the harem yay
ok let me explain the rules of the game
so you say out of words
North Korea as I was saying ok can we
stop I'm trying to express this nudity
Owen Wow so what now more fanservice is
there any reason why there's so much
fanservice in the show of course there
is this is a maturing clever show what
more can we be missing how about furries
let me check roll call what do we got
vanilla succubus flat chest jail time
artemis and incest
yeah I can use a furry look Shiro
there's another cute lolly in this world
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you bring it on
[ __ ]
the game we will play will be a virtual
shooter which will commence in a week
all right brother
what do you think we should do to win
just disappeared who just disappeared
who my brother it was my hair a minute
ago
you know remember him are you talking
about REM I'm back now I literally don't
even remember and neither does anyone
watching this let's just play this fps
already
[Music]
guys I think they're cheating Wow Steph
did you figure that out all on your own
it's not like everyone else we've played
has also chaining in their games plays
just have something useful for watching
[Music]
hey Shira yeah
let's never talk about this moment ever
again agreed thank you to be over
already did you look we're bored of this
can we just settle this with a coin toss
little does he know if I heightened my
senses I can accurately predict the site
it will land on just as planned
if you want to find out what happens
next without having to wait for a season
two that may never come then you can
read ahead in the light novels on book
Walker and you can use coupon code Giga
for five dollars off hold up is that the
actual name of this world diss board
yeah
dee is this boy what so this whole world
is like a board game like hey look at
this board yes boy this board yes boy
this board humanity I'm gonna [ __ ]
tell you hey guys hope you enjoyed that
video thank you very much to Jared could
tell whoever's leading themselves as
Giga again Vincent Mooney now can and
everyone else with patreon helping to
support me for this month and making
this video possible as mentioned if you
want to read ahead in light novel as
after this film who knows when we're
gonna get more no game no life then you
can read ahead on both Walker and use
coupon code Giga for five dollars off
your first purchase all the links are in
the description below and again thank
you so much the cast who took part in
there check them all out in the
description they are very talented
people and this would not have been half
as good without them anyway that's it
for me
I've been gig up and I'll see you all
next time